[Music]
it is time for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from the nspca
she brought along someone who needs a
safe and good home a dog amy named
david david it's not dave it's david and
he is the best boy ever and i can't wait
for him to go home to his forever family
um david is an eight-year-old uh pointer
boxer mix
uh he weighs about 70 pounds he's an
all-around sweetheart he
loves to play with tennis balls he loves
to go on walks
he especially loves his treats um as you
can see we're throwing little treats on
him to get his attention
but he's so sweet and so deserving of a
great family that will
provide him with love and exercise i
love the name too
not very often you have a very human
name for a canine
exactly and he just really fits i think
he just it suits him he's so
his full personality um i don't you know
somebody would be truly lucky to have
him
uh in their family and people can meet
him virtually right how does that work
we actually just opened up our shelter
um to in-person visits with an
appointment so you would go to
spca.org book an appointment and then
come in at that time to meet the animal
at the shelter
oh that's even better because now you
get to actually interact act with a pet
you can bring the family
and other pets right yeah when david's
case he has to be the only pet he does
not care for other dogs or cats so he
has to be the only guy in your home
but david's all david i mean look at
this guy he's a huge just
doll he's great how much does he weigh
he's 72 pounds yeah he's a vegan he's a
big boy but he's like can you imagine
this guy on your couch like just
like hey david let's watch a movie and
he would love it
what does he have a certain taste in
movies
i mean i think he's more into action
flicks if i were to guess um
you know i think that's kind of his his
genre but uh you know
he might be into romantic comedies i
don't know i think somebody needs to
give him a hole
find out i hope and i know david will
find a great home amy thank you so much
always great to see you
if you're interested in adopting david
or any pet you can go to nevadaspca.org
or call them
at three seven 702-873-77 two two